[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today is eric schmidt eric schmidt
that's
s-c-h-m-i-d-t on twitter at eric schmidt
is a technologist entrepreneur and
philanthropist he joined google in 2001
helping the company grow from a silicon
valley startup to a global technology
leader he served as chief executive
officer and chairman from 2001 to 2011
and as executive chairman and technical
advisor thereafter under his leadership
google dramatically scaled its
infrastructure and diversified its
product offerings while maintaining a
culture of innovation in 2017 he
co-founded schmidt futures a
philanthropic initiative that bets early
on exceptional people making the world
better he serves as chair of the broad
institute and formerly served as chair
of the national security commission on
artificial intelligence he is the host
of reimagine with eric schmidt a podcast
exploring how society can build a
brighter future after the covet 19
pandemic with co-authors henry a
kissinger and daniel huttenlocker eric
has a new book out titled the age of a.i
and our human future you can find him
again on twitter eric schmidt and eric
schmidt.com eric welcome back to the
show thank you i really look forward to
this conversation
i have been looking forward to this and
i want to confess first and foremost
that i have tremendous insecurity around
my lack of clarity on ai so i am really
looking forward to digging into many
facets but before we get to that
i want to pick out
henry kissinger
how did you come to collaborate
with henry kissinger
about 12 years ago i met him at a
conference called bilderberg
and my father worked for the nix
administration when i was very young
and my father
had henry as a as his hero he said he
was the most brilliant
hardest working
and he was enigmatic because he has both
a very favorable reputation but also a
very controversial reputation
so we chatted and he said
the only problem i have with google is i
think that you're going to destroy the
world
and i thought well that's a challenge
from henry kissinger
so we invited him to google where he
gave a speech and he confronted the
employees directly on the manipulation
that google was doing in his view
of the public discourse
and his criticisms were so apt and the
people enjoyed it so much that we struck
up a friendship
and although we're politically very
different with very different
backgrounds
i've come to learn that working with
someone this brilliant
at any age is phenomenal
but when your co-author is 98 it's a
special treat
i looked up the age i'm glad you
mentioned it 98
is
to what do you attribute him remaining
cognitively sharp into his late 90s
is that just good hardware out of the
box is there more to it
he works harder
than a 40 year old
i can tell you that he gets up in the
morning and he works all day he has
dinner with his wife and his family
and he works at night
and he keeps up that pace seven days a
week at 98.
i am convinced that the secret to
longevity is being a workaholic
and and the reason i say that is that
henry kissinger
at the age of 90 knew nothing about the
digital world
although he had a lot of opinions about
it
but he has mastered the digital world
and artificial intelligence
with the alacrity and the speed of
people who are just getting into it now
that's unique to him that's a gift
and that's why his analysis
of our world is so incredibly
interesting to me
all right we're going to spend a little
more time on on henry because i must
scratch this itch so you are very good
at
systematizing thinking from first
principles whether it's systematizing
innovation or hiring thinking of things
at scale there's a method to not the
madness but the outcomes
was henry's ability to
learn so quickly based on some approach
that he has to first principles or a
framework of any type that you've seen
exhibited in him
that he applies to new domains
there have been some studies about the
age at which you are your most
productive professionally
and as you know in math and science
brilliance tends to show up young in
their 20s they tend to get early awards
historians however seem to get better
with age maybe it's the accumulation of
perspective
and the accumulation of reasoning and
the depth of wisdom that is represented
by increasing age
and so
dr kissinger has
both the benefit of being a brilliant
historian and also having changed
history and lived in the moment
and today he spends a great deal of his
time with people talking to him about
current affairs and judging them
with his historical principles in mind
it is from that basis of insight
that when he looked at ai he said
this is a very much bigger thing
than people think it is and i said to
him
why
i honestly didn't know
and he said because
we're discussing artificial intelligence
as though it's a technology
this is like the beginning of the
renaissance
and i said tell me about the renaissance
what else do you say to a historian
who's famous
and we we started how about the
renaissance and he said that the
renaissance is really about the age of
reason it's about individuals being able
to think through their systems
it's about society allowing experts to
criticize other people
before the renaissance
decision making was essentially
hierarchical and from a king or a
religious leader
that change
allowed us to develop intellectual
thought
he is arguing
that we're entering a new epoch
similar to the renaissance this age of
artificial intelligence because humanity
has never had
a competitive intelligence similar
to itself but not human
i'd love to hear you elaborate just a
bit and then we're going to dig into
a whole slew of questions that i have in
front of me
how you thought about
the
composition of the co-authors on this
book and certainly would love to
to learn more about daniel i know a
little bit about daniel huttenlocker but
i'd love to hear more
and we could start with uh dr kissinger
i realized calling him henry is probably
gonna gonna give me bad karma so i'll
start with dr kissinger
is it his broad familiarity with history
as well as his knowledge of geopolitics
and statecraft that you were
hoping to augment everything else in the
book maybe you could just speak to how
you think about what each party brings
to
this project in our collaboration the
book suggestion was actually from dr
kissinger and what he basically said
is that
we have an opportunity
to architect the questions
that need to get answered in the next 10
20 30 years
i would parenthetically offer that we
didn't understand
when we invented social media 15 years
ago or so
the extraordinary and compound benefits
and costs of social media to our
society in particular our political
discourse
so armed with that knowledge that the
tech industry had invented a tool that
outstripped the governance of it at
least initially and maybe for a long
time
dr kissinger said
this
is an opportunity to ask the right
questions
we recruited
dan huttenlocker who is the dean of mit
computer science
partly because he's a good friend and
partly because
he's such a good scientist
he will make sure that our claims are
accurate
and
dan worked very hard
to get the path of ai correct
many of the books about artificial
intelligence are speculative
but i'm not aware of any book
that has both the geopolitical social
and historical context but also has the
technology correct
just to look at the opposite a
speculative
from a first-hand perspective could you
tell
a story or two about what you've seen or
experienced firsthand with ai
will you use ai today
whenever you use google search google
ads
spelling correction google translate
the story on ai
that's not really well understood is
that in the 1960s and 70s when i started
ai was going to happen within a decade
and my friends who were ai obsessed got
their phds in this area
and then everything stopped
it stopped working
and there was a period of about 20 years
which is known as the ai winter
where the systems didn't work
and then a series of mathematicians in
the 80s and 90s invented what is today
known as deep learning
i'll spare you the technical details
but the important thing about this deep
learning is it allows the manipulation
of patterns at scale
that allowed these algorithms to work
and the big breakthrough was in 2011
with a process called imagenet
where there was a contest to see if
computers could
see better than humans
and today computers can see better than
humans their vision is literally better
and i didn't realize at the time how
important sight was for everything
a car should be driven by a computer
the doctor should use an ai system to
examine you and then give him or her
recommendations on your care
i'd much rather have the computer look
at my skin rash or my
retina in my eye
because we now know from many many tests
that humans make observational mistakes
even the best but computers when
properly trained don't
so it was from this insight
that you could do vision at scale
that you began to be able to do
prediction at scale
and all of a sudden now
we're beginning to see systems that can
predict the next thing
and computers have gotten very good at
predicting what will happen next
the most recent well there are sort of
three events in the last three years
that really are the index points the
first is that um and dr kissinger wrote
an article after alphago
called the the end of history basically
and
inspired by the fact that go it was a
game that humans had played for 2500
years it was thought to be incomputable
not only did a computer
solve the game but it beat the top
humans both in korea and china i know
because i was physically there
computer against human and it was great
fun
but in that process
the computer invented some new moves and
strategies that had not been known to
humans for 2 500 years now that's a big
deal
the next thing that happened
was that at mit
a set of synthetic biologists and
computer scientists did a very
complicated trick
involving going through a hundred
million different compounds
and figuring out which compounds would
create a reaction for antibiotic use
and they came up with using this
technique
a new drug that's could not be foreseen
it's called hallison and it appears to
be the next raw scale antibiotic we
haven't had one in roughly 40 years
the third thing that happened
was that a group called openai built
what is are now called
universal models where they read
everything they could find on the web
into something called gpt-3
this is called a basically a transformer
and what happens is that
and these generative models can generate
things
so all of a sudden
you have a computer that can speak
what it knows
and these models are interesting because
you train them and you don't know what
they know
and furthermore they can't tell you you
have to ask them
so it's like a teenager
and many people think that these
universal models
are going to profoundly change our
understanding of language and thought
because there seem to be they only get
better with scale
so we've now got four or five companies
couple big ones couple startups that are
building what are called trillion
parameter models
these trillion parameter models cost a
hundred million dollars or so to make
that's how exciting this new area is so
you've got
strategy in the form of go you've got
medicine and drug discovery really
scientific discovery in the form of
hallucin and now you've got language
models and learning models in and it we
believe collectively that in the next 10
10 years this is going to come together
and transform everything
i'm just taking a breath
to let that settle in
gpt 3
really got my attention in part and i
want you to disabuse me of any
misunderstandings but
i saw
interviews generated between people who
were no longer living so i saw marcus
aurelius interviewing
let's just call mark twain mark twain
interviewing abraham lincoln and i
thought to myself
once we have enough audio and video
online if this will really simplify my
guest recruitment for the podcast
because i won't actually need to reach
out to the living human it'll be great i
won't i won't have to keep banging on
the door of oprah or anyone else i'll
just uh i'll just be able to generate an
interview it'll save me recording time
too
but you know you say that in jest but
we're busy building that
right and so let me just be clear how
the tim ferriss show would work
so you have an enormous amount of video
and audio data
so there's enough to learn to build a
tim ferriss question and answering thing
where
you would have not only your tone and
your the fun that you represent
but it would also represent the sum of
your insight
so we would say i was speaking with so
and so
right
and he or she said this what do you
think now in this particular scenario
this is long after your own passing and
all your guests passing too
there's every reason to think
that we'll be able to mimic
your intelligence and charm and wit
and that of your family your parents
your grandparents historical figures
that will be fun
the question is will it really change
society
or how will it change society i recall
being in a small meeting
sort of private meeting but the the
content i'm going to mention is public
and the discussion centered on the
legal cases that will be forthcoming
related to a lot of this technology and
there was uh at the time something
related to now i should be clear i want
to take a back step in a minute and
define artificial intelligence and what
that is so that doesn't get conflated
with other things
but in terms of developing technology
deep fakes
copyright
defamation
there's been a lot in the news at least
in the last few years related to deep
fakes of taylor swift and lawsuits
and
we are all going to have to contend with
entirely new breeds of legal cases i
would imagine so that's another
facet of this that is going to be
incredibly fascinating terrifying and
complex possibly
i would love for you if you don't mind
to
just define for me quite frankly
artificial intelligence because as as
i'm sure you have seen and can imagine
there are a lot of terms that kind of
get copy and pasted into startup decks
whenever they're hot that would be
deep learning machine learning ai
what what is
ai and what is it not
the simplest explanation for ai is a
system that gets better through learning
but it's busy learning something
and that's probably the easiest and
current definition of it
when i say ai to my non-technical
friends they typically think of a movie
that they saw
and the movie always has a robot and the
robot goes awry
and that robot is slain by a female
scientist
who triumphs
and
i propose a variant of that movie where
the computers all conspire against
humans and start killing humans
the humans notice this the computers run
away from the humans right and the
humans and a female scientist
figures out how to unplug the computers
one by one by one
that's not what ai is that's a movie
fiction
and it'll be a very long time hopefully
never they will have to deal with that
what ai really is is a system of
knowledge
that is implemented inside the cloud so
it's around you all the time
and it's very good at looking at large
data sets and predicting things
it's very good at looking and finding
patterns that humans can't see
i mentioned earlier that computers were
very good at vision
that was the first breakthrough
but what they're now doing is looking
for patterns of correlation that humans
can't see so let's imagine that on
tuesday you do something on friday
someone else does something and it turns
out that you're magically linked in the
universe such that tuesday causes friday
but it's not a pattern that's apparent
computers can discover that pattern that
needle in a haystack particularly well
when you operate this stuff at scale
you end up with systems that look
human-like
because they can aggregate data and they
can think what you think they can
generate
a solution there's a technology called
gans generative adversarial networks
where the computer can generate
candidates and another network says not
good enough not good enough not good
enough until they find it
gans have been used for example to build
pictures of actresses and actors that
are fake but look so real you're sure
you know them
so one of the concerns the one of the
real concerns about ai
is that it's going to be very difficult
to tell the difference between
information and misinformation
and i'll give you an example let's
assume that all of your readers and
listeners are obviously human
and that the standard rules of humans
apply to all of us
there's something called anchoring bias
there's something called recency bias
you know people aren't completely
rational computers nor should they we
don't want them to be we love humans
but let's imagine the computer gets
enough of such people and it figures out
that if i say the following outrageous
thing first you'll always believe me and
the computer discovers this and so all
of a sudden
everything it does boom boom boom
i thought a lot about the way
politicians speak if you watch carefully
they take a set of phrases and they
repeat them over and over again they're
simple phrases that's anchoring they're
trying to get the audience their voters
to start with this fact and then judge
past it well computers will be
incredibly good
at exploiting them
that means that the world our social
world around us within the next decade
will become impossibly confusing
because there's so many actors that will
want to misinform us businesses
politicians our opponents for fun god
knows we don't know how to manage that
when you mention things coming together
in some fashion in the next 10 years
could you speak to
if and how
generalized or general artificial
intelligence fits into that because i
know that's a that's a big question for
a lot of people including those who
don't really understand the technology
when
uh generalized artificial intelligence
will arrive so to speak i think it's
important to establish some of these
terms
agi stands for artificial general
intelligence
and agi refers to computers that are
human-like
in their strategic
and capability
today's computers and the today's
algorithms are extraordinarily good at
generating content misinformation
guidance helping you with science and so
forth but they're not self-determinative
they don't actually have the notion of
who am i and what do i do next
if you ask gpt3 who it is
gpt-3 will say i'm a computer
but it won't give you
a philosophical basis
for its existence its purpose and how
it's determining where it goes
that is the distinction between ai and
agi in my view
now within the community the agi
optimists think that within 10 years we
will have such computers
the pessimists think that it will be far
longer if ever
so let's say 15 years from now
it may be possible to have computers
that have a sense of self-determination
that they know roughly what they're
trying to achieve
against a broader objective
many people think that this will become
an enormous competition between humans
because remember that those computers
will be faster learners than humans
they'll have access to more data than
humans
other people believe that they'll be
fundamentally flawed
because they won't have the nuance they
won't have the background they won't
have the cultural background of the
countries that we all grow up in and the
cultures we grow in we don't really know
my own view
is that this will occur
but that the amount of computation
required to do this will be so great
that they'll only be a few of them
and furthermore they'll become so
important
that they'll be like nuclear weapons
and let me tell you why
let's imagine you have a truly evil
person who encounters this agi what's
the first question they'll ask them tell
me how to kill a million people
obviously a terrible
terrible thing to ask and answer
and the agi because it doesn't have
morals
could actually answer
it could actually say well do this this
this and this and furthermore it could
articulate something that's not
generally known because it knows
everything
so i think a fair reading of these agis
is that they're going in the in the most
extreme form they're going to be so
powerful
that they're going to have to be
protected
we don't want them broadly used they're
going to have to be used in specialized
scenarios
now such an intelligence will be
enormously valuable
for drug discovery material science
climate change
making the world more efficient making
making people more educated and imagine
with an agi you could say tell me how to
teach a million children english better
and he could figure that out
because it could in its own thinking to
agree it's thinking it could look at all
the patterns figure out how to do it and
you could actually ask it to write the
program
the beginning of this is today there are
companies that are offering tools which
will help you write code
they don't know what code you're trying
to write but once you start it can fill
in a bunch of it for you
that's the beginning of this phenomena
in the extreme case
there are scientists and basically
science fiction around
the future that could use something
called
the singularity
which is the point where the computer
evolution is so much faster than humans
now that's speculation
when you talk to people in my world
most people think the singularity will
occur 20 years from whenever you ask
them that question
so that would say
2041.
where do you fall
if if i may ask your personal opinion
assuming and this is a big assumption
that there are people on the techno
optimist and pessimistic side who are
very technically sophisticated
what is your
current
best guess or intuitive feel however you
want to answer it on the arrival of
something we would consider agi
the top scientists the greatest
inventors in this area
collectively believe that we need one or
two more breakthroughs
to get to volition
to get to consciousness in the way that
humans do it when you wake up in the
morning you have so many choices of how
to spend your time how do you choose
right
how do you handle unplanned situations
and all of that
most people believe that
the computers that i'm talking about
will become enormously valuable partners
my physicist friend i said to him what
would you like the computer to do and he
says it's really simple
there are so much physics being written
about now that i don't have time to read
it all
and i want the physics assistant
to go and read everything
figure out what disagrees with each
other suggest things for me to think
about
while i'm sleeping
the biologists have similar questions
people who are philosophers want new
insights read everything help me think
through this
i believe that in the next decade that
will be the primary achievement in ai
and that is extraordinary
because it means for example that we can
answer questions in physics math
medicine and so forth that have been
unanswerable
we've not been able to understand the
behavior of subatomic particles we can
do it now
enormous breakthroughs but that's not
the same thing as real human
intelligence i think it's going to take
another breakthrough or two i know this
is maybe trying
to look into the crystal ball with too
much intensity but
could you elaborate on
well if those breakthroughs are known
what they are what like what the
problems are that need to be solved are
they known problems there are people who
are working really hard on
the question of goals
and
the computer systems
have
knowledge which they cannot explain
which we can think of as intuition
so the system gets trained and it it
knows things but if you ask it why it
knows it it can't tell you that's
intuition yeah
so the question here is how much more
computational power and scenario
planning do you have to do
to look at all the different choices
that you have every day
there are people who believe
that it's perhaps a hundred times more
computing power
and computing power goes up
you know it doubles every two to three
years right now
and so that gives you a sense that
within 15 years
it's possible to imagine that amount of
computing power
required to do this
and the reason we use computing power is
one we don't have a better metric but
also because
the computer doesn't think the way
humans do the computer looks at
scenarios and eliminates it says well
what if this and what if this and what
if this
and
the computer itself is eliminating this
choice this choice this choice this
choice and finally settles on a good
choice
so many people believe that the
compounding of knowledge
will take what we say a couple orders of
more magnitude
which is why these computers are likely
at least initially to be few extremely
expensive
and very very large
does the 15-year
hypothetical time horizon
factor in and and this is me getting
into very
slippery territory since i'm
non-technical but does it does that
factor in the potential applications of
quantum computing
for at least 20 years people have been
focusing on this notion of a different
kind of computer called a quantum
computer
and quantum computers are hard to
explain but basically think of them as
they do all the computations at the same
time
so instead of going chunk
all the chunks go at the same time
and the term quantum supremacy means
that everything occurs at once
rather than taking the computer time to
go through each of the mathematical
calculations
the reason that this is of such great
interest is that one of the core aspects
of security in the computer age
is the difference between multiplication
and division
and with quantum computers you could
break all of the codes and all of the
secrets and all of the keys and all of
that that we all use every day
so a lot of people think that national
security groups are busy working hard to
do that the consensus in the industry is
that we are eight to ten years away from
that
and the way they get there is that the
current quantum computers have an error
rate
because it's not perfect
when they operate they're essentially
mimicking a natural process digitally
and
google showed last year
that they could do this on a computer
that would have taken a million years
that took roughly 10 seconds
in because of it so we know it's
possible
the question now is how do you actually
build a real one that's useful
if you had a real one you could instead
of simulating a physical process the
typical one is called annealing where
two metals basically merge and this is
crucial for
high high strength steel and titanium
and things like this
and is of great business interest
but the same thing would apply to ai if
it worked because the algorithm instead
of looking at all these different
scenarios would examine them all at the
same time pick the the best one
technically the one with the lowest
energy state
the current quantum
learning is not proceeding very quickly
it's a very hard problem
so my assumption is that quantum
learning will occur in our lifetimes but
not very soon
thank you
and for people listening who want to do
a real deep dive on
quantum learning quantum computing
i have a conversation with steve
jervitson that goes very
deeply into this subject matter and it
really does start to be a mind-bender
when you get into the details it is
quite something i want to ask you you
mentioned
what the philosophers might ask for in
terms of augmentation or help you
mention the biologists the physicists i
am going to ask you i'm just planting a
seed
what
uh eric schmidt
might
use ai technology for in the future but
before i get there i want to just look
at a snapshot of current day
what are
some of the coolest or most impressive
things that you've seen ai figure out on
its own
well i mentioned this new drug
and the new drug and drug discovery
will accelerate combination of the mrna
achievements
plus the ability now to essentially
replace the way the drug lab works
you know my sort of stereotype is the
chemist wakes up in the morning and says
let's try the following seven compounds
they try the seven compounds none of
them work and at five o'clock they go
home
to have dinner and think watch
television the next morning they think
of another seven
well the computer can do as i mentioned
100 million
in a day
that's a huge accelerant in what they're
doing
i'm very interested in the development
of humans
together with ai systems
and the example i would offer is you
have a two-year-old
and the two-year-old gets a plush toy
it happens to have a i inside of it
and by agreement as this child ages
every year they get a better toy
and of course the toy gets smarter
we don't know at all
what happens when a child's best friend
is not a human
or a dog
we don't know
what that does to the child's bonding to
other children
to their parents
i mean you know frustrated parents and
the kid is busy and they give them a
computer
and do whatever you want
but imagine if that computer is
learning talking thinking
educating at the same time it's a
godsend right
it could be but what is it teaching yeah
right what is it teaching what are its
norms what are its values will such a
child end up being very salted with real
humans and really come comfortable with
digital
we honestly just don't know
we know that people get attached to
inanimate objects
and that there are many religions where
inanimate objects have
what we would think of as a bit of a
soul
we mentioned this in the book
but we don't know
i'll give you another example with
elderly a lot of studies indicate that
the elderly are very lonely which is
sort of sad
and
imagine if their best friend is a
digital friend what does that do does
that
extend their lives does it make them
crankier
does it make their loneliness more
perverse i don't think we know yet
yeah or is that digital friend and
emulation of a relative that's right so
so now we get you know our our
grandmother as an example and we
recreate her husband
and what does it do when she can chat
with her husband who's now passed away
we honestly don't know when i go through
and i look at these
these technologies they're really four
qualities in ai that are different
the first is it's
imprecise it's imprecise in that you
can't tell you exactly what it's doing
and it makes mistakes
don't use it for life critical decisions
you want a human who can make mistakes
consulting a computer you don't want the
computer flying the airplane and maybe
never but certainly not for a long time
it's dynamic
in the sense that it's changing right it
can learn it can assess the situation
around it
and change its behavior this is the ai
now
it has emergent behavior
emergent means things that come out that
we don't expect
right
strange things now we've seen this a bit
with social media
i don't think anyone expected the
government interference in the elections
in 2016. that was an emergent behavior
it was unexpected
by humanity using these tools and those
were not ai powered
and then the final point is it's capable
of learning
so you've got a system using the child
scenario you've got a child that's got a
teddy bear that looks like a teddy bear
but it's imprecise dynamic emergent and
capable of learning what's the teddy
bear learning
right
so the teddy bear is watching tv too
and the teddy bear says look i think
this show sucks and the kid says i agree
with you
again we don't understand the
implication especially on formative
behaviors
there's a whole nother set of arguments
about national security and how
governments will work and how
dominance games will play and who will
be winners and losers from this
technology that we don't really
understand and we talk about that
well let's let's
actually touch on that for a second
and this is something on the minds of a
lot of a lot of folks certainly i know a
lot of investors who are trying to
understand
ai in the capacity of acting as an
investor i'm not saying we go there but
uh you have
spoken to congress about say uh china's
announced ambitions with a.i
10 to 15 years isn't that far away it's
really close and certain things
move very slowly certain facets of say
government move quite slowly regulation
what types of corners are most important
to look around and
i'd love to hear you speak a little bit
more about the geopolitical components
i was fortunate to be the chairman of an
ai commission for congress we just
released our report very proud of it
and we studied a lot about where the
world is in ai not so much on these agi
questions but
the more tactical things that i've been
discussing
we concluded that the united states is
slightly ahead of china
in these areas that china has a
national program to focus on this
they're pouring
literally billions and billions of
dollar equivalents into this they
generate four times more engineers as we
do just because of population size and
they're extremely focused on dominance
of ai by 2030 which is soon
in our report we speak a great deal
about what the government needs to do to
help it starts with more research
more access to more data making sure our
values are represented so we don't end
up with systems that have prejudice and
so forth and violate both our laws as
well as our morals we talk about
partnerships and all of this kind of
stuff the reason this is so important
is that pretty much every national
security issue will be tainted or
controlled by ai in the future
if you think about cyber attacks
the most obvious
war scenario in the future is the
following
north korea decides to attack the united
states
it begins its attack china decides this
is a bad idea
and blocks the attack
america's defenses are
awake alert america announces a
counter-attack which stops this
the entire war
that i just described
took about 10 milliseconds
give you another example in the military
there's a a presumption of human control
which is very important
i was part of a team that wrote some of
the ai ethics that are now used by the
u.s military
which i obviously strongly support
and they say we want the principle of
human control human authorization
so let me give you an example
you're on a ship
and a new kind of missile let's say a
very fast hypersonic missile is coming
in which people are developing
countries are and it's coming in so fast
that the ship can't see it the humans
can't see it but the ai has figured it
out
so the ai says to the commander
in 15 seconds a missile is going to be
showing up and it's going to destroy you
and your entire crew
i recommend that you press this button
to launch the counter attack
and the human says
14
13 12 10.
what do i do
and at three seconds that human is going
to press that button
so the compression of time
the amount of data
and the potential for error
creates a whole set of problems around
military doctrine
now everything that we
live in today deterrence all of the
other things that we've that we are all
of us are familiar with great power
competition
are concepts that were invented over the
last hundred years ago
and dr kissinger actually invented much
of the containment strategy in the 50s
and 60s
before he was in government
as part of a team that sort of invented
all this work
so i asked him what does this look like
now
how would you address this now
and his answer is
let's get an equivalent team of people
and try to figure these things out
containment for example doesn't work
containment is about keeping another
country from getting something
because these algorithms and this
software is pervasive
leaks and it leaks through ideas and
through discovery not just from criminal
leaking
it's not like
los alamos where you could keep a secret
so the way to maintain competitive
dominance that is national security
is to invest in these areas both in
terms of data and algorithms and to be
excellent
but also to begin
some kind of dialogue
about what the limitations of automatic
war are
so another example uh just to make and
i'll make one up now so the scenario i
described of the 10 millisecond war
so let's say that china in this case
develops an agi ahead of everyone else
and this agi is thought to be so
powerful
that it could defeat any of our defenses
then the logic on the american side
would be to do a preemptive attack to
prevent that possibility
and that's destabilizing of great power
competition
so you want to avoid an arms race
and an arms race in ai could look a lot
like the arms race that we went through
in the 50s and 60s
and people have forgotten how much of
our
military industrial complex how much
money and so forth was devoted to build
more than 30 000 nuclear weapons all of
which could destroy the world many many
times over
many many rounds of negotiation got
those numbers down to 3 000 4 000 such
weapons which are still plenty to
destroy everything
it's an example of
overreach so i worry that because we
don't have an agreement
on even what the rules are what the
landscape of limitations are
we don't have diplomats who can have the
conversations
and no single national security group no
single country is going to self-limit
and say oh we're not going to do that
this is not costa rica which doesn't
have a military
so the natural course of logic will be
the development of these incredibly fast
and potentially destabilizing weapons
for which we don't have a language
so i'll i think i'll just act as a
stand-in for listeners
that sounds very terrifying i mean it
does sound
not just terrifying but challenging to
address and i i may come back to that
and questions of
policy and geopolitics
i want to ask you the personal question
that i alluded to earlier before i let
that go which is
what could you achieve or what would you
want to achieve or ask of ai
in the future that would allow you to do
things you cannot do today
almost every hard problem in
our society
is based on
either the computers can't figure it out
we don't have enough data
we honestly don't know how to solve it
i'd i'd like to get some breakthroughs
so i'd like for example to get better
climate models
in my philanthropy i funded a group at
caltech
which figured out a way to predict
climate better using an ai system that
would model clouds
i didn't know this but it turns out
clouds are really complicated
and so they used an ai system to
approximate
how clouds would behave which allowed
them to solve the prediction problem
it's called clima cli ma
over and over again
i would like the ai system to
educate me and entertain me
and keep me curious
about the dynamism of the world
speaking personally
when i look at the news feeds we're
obsessed about politics and president
trump and so forth
to the point where you get the
impression that there's nothing else
going on
but one of the great things about
humanity and our world is it's
incredibly dynamic we never hear what
those people are doing
i'd like to see if we could figure out a
way to advance against these really hard
problems
let's get some solutions around mental
health let's get some solutions around
drug abuse let's get some solutions
around the rise of inequality
and let's have our computers help us
with those solutions
i'd love to talk about
this is something you know a lot more
about than i do but
how programming may be able
or
incapable of addressing
morals and ethics
and
i'll give an example probably a bad
example and not technically accurate but
it seems like we're already at a point
with say the development of autonomous
vehicles
where
questions that might have been presented
in a
freshman philosophy class like the
trolley problem
actually need to be programmed on some
level in in the sense that cars need to
make decisions if there is an accident
they need to say
choose between going on the sidewalk
at high speed and hitting
three
elderly or
swerving right and hitting one child
let's just say i mean not that we would
ever want to be in that type of
situation but these things happen
do you how do you foresee
computer scientists attempting to if if
this is even going to be an objective
instill ethics and morals into
ai
and and does it just require a level of
self-awareness that perhaps we don't
have
i'm just i'm curious
how you might think about that
there are many many computer scientists
working on this every major computer
science program i'm aware of has a
computer science and ethics research
project
there are a lot of problems
one of the first problems is that
computer science and ai
are based on learning
data literally learning
and therefore the the information that
they're learning has biases
so whatever prejudice and bias and
religious problems that society has
around it the computer will absorb
so the research is how to identify those
biases because remember in many cases
these systems cannot tell you what they
know
and how to mediate them
it's pretty clear to me that there's
going to end up being the system that
knows everything and then there's going
to be a supervisory system that limits
it
so two different systems one will be the
knowledge system and another one which
will keep it
within some guardrails
so the question that was asked is not a
permissible question don't send it to
the system
and you're going to have all sorts of
problems my favorite self-driving car
problem
is here in new york
eventually
all the cars are self-driving
because it's such a crowded grid and
traffic moves
perfectly
the engineers at google and everywhere
else have figured out exactly how to
optimize
under a set of assumptions the aggregate
and average delivery time of a human
from place to place it's a perfect
computer science solution
so now we've got a woman who's going
into labor
who needs to get there faster
now
is there a button
in the car that says
i'm pregnant i'm about to give birth and
i need to get there faster
okay so she presses the button and
somehow it works how do we make sure
that a gentleman who's lying
cannot press the same button
in the trolley problem
all of these are of the form how do you
choose one life or the
other
the correct answer is don't kill
anything
right
and so we're gonna have to find ways to
avoid being in the situation where you
have to choose between three old people
and one child
and these are the great debates of
philosophers and how do we value life
and so forth but i think we should start
with the premise that the system should
be designed
such that it that it optimizes overall
overall happiness and overall wealth in
the societal sense of wealth
but these trade-offs so we as an example
we tolerate double parking
we tolerate
people speeding we don't track every car
and give them an automatic ticket every
time they go above the 30 mile an hour
speed limit by one mile
but technically that would be easy
if you want to eliminate the vast
majority of crime
in our society
put cameras in every public space with
face recognition
it's by the way illegal to do so
but if you really care about crime to
the exclusion of personal freedom and
the freedom of of not being surveilled
then we could do it so the technology
gives you these choices and those are
not choices that computer scientists
should make
those are choices for society i use the
surveillance cameras as an example to
say that
in britain they're very widely accepted
when you're in britain on a street
you're on camera in the united states
it's partial sometimes you are sometimes
you're not but in germany with a long
history of the stasi
they are very violently opposed to such
surveillance these are three different
democracies that have made the choices
in different ways
so i don't think that computer
scientists and the tech industry should
make these decisions but i do think what
we should tell people is our tools give
you this range of choices
if you look at leadership in china china
is a couple generations ahead in
surveillance
they can actually spot you in your gate
now the way you walk not just your face
recognition this is not something we
want to lead in
i'm just letting that
all sink in for a second it's one of
those conversations for me it's great
there's so much to chew on uh and
i'm gonna i'm gonna take a
take a 90 degree turn
back to
the the physicists and the biologists
and others who will
be able to
consult ai
uh
in the way i think it was presented
to help assimilate new information new
developments get up to speed they can't
possibly
even with physical constraints
keep up or digest the amount that they
would like to digest
now many people dr kissinger certainly
over decades and
many many others
spend a lot of their time
ingesting information and that could be
in the form of reading it could be in
the form of conversations like this
and i suppose there are two questions
one is
how do you think
thought workers or humans will spend
their time once that ingestion is
dramatically reduced or removed
and along with that
if we get to the point where
that is possible
and there's a question of how it would
be conveyed to the human
how far are we from there simply being a
direct brain computer interface where
that information is somehow
seamlessly
integrated into our consciousness
without being
spoken or imparted to us
externally
to answer the last part first
we are in our industry we're working on
direct brain connections of one kind or
another they're all in startups
they're all speculative at this point
they've shown some
gains if you think about 200 years from
now
to pick a random number
it's probable that we'll know the
complete details of the human brain how
it's wired how it works
so if you think far enough in advance
well past our lifetimes it's probable
that we'll know a great deal about how
to manipulate the brain externally to
the brain we'll understand how it works
we'll understand the wiring
maybe there'll be some attachment and so
forth
most people think that that will occur
no one has any idea when
when you go back to the
the gains
you want to get the basis of what the
next 20 years look like and i think it's
fair to say
that we're going to be awash in
information and misinformation
at a scale that is overwhelming and it's
already overwhelming
so the most likely scenario
is that each of us will have the
equivalent of an ai communications
assistant
that will watch
like while you and i are speaking my ai
assistant is watching what's going on
and it knows my preferences it knows
what i care about and it has a good
sense of judgment
and when we're finished speaking it'll
say by the way
over here in arkansas the following
thing happened that you might want to
check out
more importantly
this ai assistant
will battle with the misinformation
assistance
and it'll say prove to me that you're a
human
before i expose you to my human
and so you can imagine a scenario where
the solution to the misinformation
problem and the solution to this
information space problem
is that each of us has our own ai
assistant
that
think of it as the equivalent of a phone
although in practice it's a super
computer that's accessed through your
phone or equivalent
this sort of keeps you sane
if you go back to my earlier comments
about children
we have no idea what the rules should be
for that assistant
so let me give you an example we've
learned unfortunately in the last few
years that there are still horrific
racial prejudice
horrifically hateful people
well they get an assistant too
is their assistant going to
pattern their racism
or their misogyny
or their violence against children or
all these sort of hateful behaviors
because these are part of humanity too
or will there be some regulation that
says that your assistant has to be
politically correct
it has to say are you a he is she or you
know in other words how will society
resolve that
and my prediction will be that each
government and each culture will adopt
different rules about them
but they're not going to be unregulated
what we've learned and i've learned
really the hard way
is that the technology that that i
helped work on and that is being
invented now is no longer optional
15 years ago i used to give this speech
saying look you hate the internet
turn your phone off
have dinner with your family do whatever
you're going to do
but get off
and that's not a practical
answer today
the internet is no longer
optional it's essential partly because
of the pandemic but because of
e-commerce and business and knowledge
and so forth
so it's going to get regulated and the
question is how and under what terms
well i've i've i believe read you
use the
analogy of the telephone
maybe maybe i'm making that up but
in the sense that
just because there are bad actors who
can use the telephone
for
wrongdoing for crime etc it doesn't mean
we eliminate the telephone it means that
we have means of regulation and
enforcement
and so on i guess the the telephone by
comparison seems to be such a
clean
although increasingly maybe not discrete
system
what are the most important next steps
from
from your perspective with respect to
even thinking about regulation the best
questions to ask or just concrete steps
well i always like to use self-driving
cars because everyone can relate to this
so
in california there's a concept called a
rolling stop
the california roll yes
and and when you come to the stop sign
you sort of forget to fully stop you
roll through so the police car
policeman comes over and says you did
the rolling stop and i say to the
policeman
sir i did not
and then it said who did and it's and
then the car says i did sir
and the policeman says why and the car
says i don't know
very frustrating for the police officer
yeah so
who gets the ticket
so your choices are the human
the car itself the manufacturer of the
car
or the data that the car was trained
with
right so that's the debate to have
give you another example
i feel very strongly in favor of free
speech for humans
but i don't feel very strongly for
amplification by computers
and so what we're seeing now is we're
seeing humans who have wacky
wacky false conspiratorial ideas what
have you
get picked up and amplified in these
systems
that drives everyone crazy because we
can't tell the difference between a
genuine social movement and concern
versus a single crazy person who has an
amplified idea that seems plausible but
is basically false we have no way of
falsifying such things
that's something that's got to get
sorted out
we can't live in an information space
that is so full of misinformation
and manipulation that we can't get
through the day
when we go back in the book to talk
about the renaissance we say this is a
new epoch
because in addition to this
misinformation that we've been speaking
about
we also have never had a situation
in our human experience where there was
an intelligence that was similar to ours
but not the same that was non-human
and so imagine a situation where these
intelligences exist
and they can be consulted
well who gets to consult them what
happens to their answers
so for example if it's an oracle do you
have a rule that every answer from the
oracle is published to the world
because it's presumably beneficial but
what if it's a private question or a
secret what if it's being used in
national security again these are
questions that we have not resolved so
what we say is these are really hard
questions what happens when the ai
perceives aspects of reality that humans
do not
that it sees a connection there are
physicists who talk about new universes
and new worlds and you can imagine a
situation where there's some thing that
we as humans cannot conceive of
because of our limited intelligence but
the computer detects it and then we say
oh my god
in math there's a
a long story about
an object that lives in a
two-dimensional world
and the third dimension appears but if
you're in a two-dimensional world that
you don't you never see the third
dimension so you're always confused
so what if this ai can find a
dimensionality of the world that we as
humans not a single one of us can
understand
and we're now confused
we don't know how to handle that
what what happens another example is
dr kissinger believes
that
i'll paraphrase
when something is not understandable by
humans
they will perceive it as an act of god
or they will resist it
and you can imagine a situation where
you end up with nativists
who decide that this world that i'm
describing is so impossibly unpleasant
that they turn it all off and they go to
the equivalent of
the woods of pennsylvania and they say
leave me alone
and you have other people who learn to
drive it and manipulate it for good and
evil
that you'll you'll have a choice and
then one final scenario to think about
goes like this
let's say you're older
the kids are grown
and it's time for you to
to take a break from the world
so you put on headphones
and vr glasses
and in those vr glasses and headphones
you have a life of you as a much younger
person
a much more beautiful handsome wealthier
stronger whatever
with the friends that you remember of
the time recreated even though they may
have passed away
that might be a more fun life for you
every day
than the life that you have in this
scenario
what happens when we lose people i call
that crossing to the other side
when they wake up in the morning they
just want to be over there
that will happen too it strikes me that
you know science fiction can be
prescient in some instances and it
doesn't make it
future fiction it just makes it current
day fiction but there's i don't want to
say predictive power but i think of
really good science fiction
of course subjective but
snow crash the description of the
metaverse or you have some of william
gibson's work i'm just curious do you
or have you read science fiction much
yourself
uh well neuromancer is particularly good
if you look at seven eves
a recent book
it's an extraordinary composition of of
the importance of of humanity surviving
the destruction of the earth
and in seven eaves toward the end
in their science fiction they have
assistance
that have a funny name that serve this
function that i'm describing
so as usual science fiction anticipates
many of the things in technology
but if you think about it
we
believe today from the reformation
that we have the sole power of
understanding reality
but at some point
that's not going to be true
when that happens what will our
self-conception
look like
how will we conceive of ourselves
how will we organize ourselves
how will we value ourselves right
well let me let me ask you
some follow-up questions on
this word reality and perception because
uh it it makes me think this
conversation makes me think of and maybe
getting the the full name wrong so i'll
correct it in the show notes if i do but
i believe
his name is donald hoffman who is a
cognitive scientist also computer
scientist at uc irvine and
here's a book that's called i believe
the case against reality and also a ted
talk
and
really the
the general exploration focuses on
how
easy it is to prove and demonstrate that
we are optimized for very few things
right reproduction principle among them
and that what we perceive is not some
objective reality
yeah
and that if you were a mantis shrimp for
instance you would see things very
differently they have these incredible
optics systems
and so on and so forth what does the
word reality mean to you
and
how do you think personally
that might change once we are deeper
into the era of
well-developed ai
50 years ago reality
was television and normal life
today reality is this online world
that is constantly demanding attention
constantly full of stressors of one kind
or another
constantly demanding your engagement
because that's the way it's built
the engagement is around monetization uh
spreading information and misinformation
and so forth
everyone i know is being driven crazy by
the explosion of that
so i think that in the next decade
the explosion will continue
and the
solutions will need to be developed
because more and more the digital world
becomes the real world
an example that i used which is
for example you can see it in the movie
ready player one
where people cross over and they spend
most of their time in a in a virtual
world
is true for many many teenagers
and there's every reason to believe in
the next 10 or 20 years those worlds
will become extraordinarily
sophisticated
so in a contest where i'll give you a
simple example
at google
we
because there was so much going on we
developed a pattern where people would
be in meetings but they would also be
doing their email at the same time
and we became very good at doing two
things at once and this was a cultural
norm
but i had to put in a rule that when you
had outsiders in the room you couldn't
do this
because it was seen as so incredibly
rude
which it is
but it was a cultural norm that we
adopted and invented and worked well
so
you can see that the addiction cycle
and and our world is largely now locked
into addiction cycles whether it's drug
related or whether it's technology
related or it's attention related i mean
again humans are like this
i am very very concerned that we will
lose
perspective on what reality really is
humans are not built for the kind of
stressors
that occur every day we just aren't
organized we're organized around you
know the campfire and the lion and that
sort of thing which didn't occur at warp
speed
and so i'm assuming that this
pressure on human development
this sort of craziness this constant
anxiety
will lead to more neuroses more paranoia
not less
and that people will then have to figure
out a way just in the same way that
parents are trying to keep their kids
offline some of the time because kids
are on online from the moment they wake
up to the moment they go to sleep kids
want them go play ball for an hour i'm
taking your phone away
we're going to have to do the same thing
for adults
what rules or
constraints do you have for yourself
around
social media or other types of
digital stimuli
but one of my friends said that he
stopped watching television because he
reads all his news online
and i thought okay well that's a
reasonable time trade-off of course
you're you're changing one stressor for
another
but that says i only have time for one
i've chosen the online world
and so i think the first question is is
there's limited time
and then the second thing is you've got
to have some rules so for me
i'm online all the time but i try to
turn it off during dinner i can usually
get it
done for about an hour
so the question is when you go
without it for a while give another
example in 2012
a group of us went to north korea and we
went from beijing
and this was at a time it was legal
to do so as an american and we left our
phones in the beijing airport in a
trusted person
and we sat in the lounge as the plane
was about to take us to pyongyang
without our phones and it's the
strangest feeling
and by the time we got there and got
settled in the hotel it's a group of
maybe 10
we started talking to each other which
we would never have done
and within three days
we were best friends
the moment we got back to beijing and
got our phones we were on them
we lost all context of what we were
doing and we were back in the soup
so
there's going to be some in the same
sense that people go to spa vacations
there's going to be have to be some
equivalent of a spa vacation from your
devices
yeah i'm wondering what
what type of agency
humans will be able to
harness to
position themselves competitively in the
world of ai it brings up so many
questions i mean such as the ai
assistant will there be tiered
assistance and will
the well-off be able to afford better
assistance i mean certainly the better
off have different types of access now
that help them to separate signal from
noise better than the majority
so that will probably continue to be the
case
do you think there and there's no right
answer here by the way uh for me do you
think there's anything uniquely human
that ultimately
we will be able to
find
value in in a world of
of agi for instance
a lot of people are speculating
that
the eventual future is a much richer
world
where people are largely idle and that
the units of production are so efficient
this is food production buildings and so
forth that everyone can live like a
millionaire
which means they don't have to work and
a lot of people would prefer not to work
many of the jobs they find not that
interesting and they have hobbies that
are more interesting to them and so
forth
it's possible that will be true
it's also possible that that world is
dystopian
because humans need meaning
so i think the answer to your question
has a lot to do with whether the systems
produce
more meaning for humans
or less meaning
if the computer replaces me that's less
meaning
if the computer augments me it's more
meaning
and i'll say very clearly that this is
true at every level of society
so there will be a small number of
countries
the us will be one china will be another
there will be others which will be the
leaders in these technologies
and because the way network platforms
work those leaders will get far ahead of
the other countries
so there is going to be a division
between the ai enabled
powerhouse countries
and the following countries who are
using it but not inventing it
that divide will lead to enormous
societal and economic changes
which we don't fully understand
put another way if you don't have a
leading university in your country
that's doing this kind of stuff
you're going to be left out
at the human level
some people will be comfortable
in this new in
and very very curiosity driven very
interesting age
but an awful lot of people will feel
displaced
will they be less motivated or more
motivated another example
we should be able using these tools to
build learning systems that teach in the
most efficient way possible each and
every person we know people learn
differently
but the old you know rear ends and seats
30 people in front of a chalkboard is an
outmoded concept
so there will be a completely different
way for kids to learn and grow up which
has got to be good because it'll
maximize their potential so you've got a
person who's been maximized their
potential will the economic system give
them opportunity to be maximally
potentialized
give you another example we i use
science examples but let's imagine that
you really want to be
a painter or a musician
well in the future the ai you'll say to
the ai system i'm imagining a song
about a woman and a riverboat you know
in new orleans and you know it's a sad
song but it has willows in the
background
or something like that and the computer
will generate a song for you
which won't be as good as what you can
do
but you'll listen to it and you'll say
oh that then stimulates your idea
okay so i want to invent a form of
cubism that's different from picasso so
the computer will then
go through a series of scenarios of
cubism that doesn't look like picasso
and i'll say
i can do better and then i'll be
stimulated
so
the people who can engage in that i used
musicians and painters and scientists
and thinkers and writers
are going to be the economic winners but
what about everyone else
yeah
it's uh it's it's a really great
question i also immediately start
thinking this just shows you how boring
i am but about
questions of copyright and intellectual
property you know will you have some
type of
blockchain identified
and verified assistant
who is kind of one-to-one correlated
with your
your identity and social security number
therefore you can copyright and own
anything that
ai helps you to generate or generates
itself for that matter it's going to
raise all sorts of questions
i think we should build that company
immediately you and i let's found it
right now
the the use of uh blockchain to do
authentication is going to be central in
this world because otherwise how do you
know where do you know the source who
invented this how did it actually happen
yeah well we should talk about it
we're going to need source
authentication
very very much in this
i was looking back at
my notes from our last conversation we
covered a lot of ground i recommend
everyone also listen to the last
conversation because we went so deeply
into your your background your history
the trajectory different mentors it was
a great conversation i really enjoyed it
and we spoke a lot about bill joy and
when
in the notes at least if i'm
remembering correctly once he became a
venture capitalist he would read
research papers figure out who the best
authors or participants were and then
call them and ask what's the most
interesting thing in your field and i
would love to hear
any examples of
startups bigger companies
academics particular teams at
universities any any
anyone or any groups that stand out to
you is doing very very interesting
things in the sphere of ai
well there are two well-known examples
in agi one is called deep mind which is
in the uk it's owned by google i've been
heavily involved with them
and another one is open ai which is the
inventor of gpt3
which has a big partnership with
microsoft
those two are probably the largest
focuses in these new areas uh so-called
reinforcement learning so-called
generative learning
and there are a couple of other labs
there's a series of university projects
i've been funding
ai applied science in the leading
universities
and
the ai science
goes something like this
the physicists know how something works
but our computers can't calculate it
it's too complicated a calculation but
they can make an approximation
so often in science a
ai system is used to approximate
something
good enough
so that we can understand how the system
works
the most obvious area where this will
play out will be in biology
another friend of mine said that math is
like is to physics what ai will be to
biology
you needed math to understand how
physics worked you'll need ai to
understand how biology works because
it's so incredibly complicated
we still don't understand how to model a
cell we still don't understand how the
brain is organized
there are so many basic things that you
would think as humans we would want to
know that we are that have not been
calculable for us and that's where all
the great discoveries will be
you know i have to have to share
something
just because it's
it's it's on
this topic in a sense
i have
a
set of papers from the late richard
feynman on which
he drew the krebs cycle and i just found
that
crossover so to speak
so fascinating and we don't have to go
deeply into feynman but certainly one of
the people i've paid a lot of attention
to biology is incredibly complex and i
was thinking of the examples you've
given
and thinking of say protein folding or
trying to identify
receptors and the shapes of receptors or
even structure the and modify the shapes
of receptors
the process as you've already said is so
incredibly labor intensive and we've
tried all sorts of things to try to pick
up the slack using idle computers in a
distributed fashion
but
once you have
ai as a player on the field i mean that
it could change things so fundamentally
as you
as you mentioned with that one example i
think hallison was the example that you
mentioned
it's a big big deal
and i'm i wonder how ai may augment
natural prospecting since nature
oftentimes the molecules we identify in
nature are just so beyond the wildest
imaginations of anyone who would start
from scratch
with
a say ground-up synthetic approach
raises so many so many interesting
questions
it's worth
noting that there were there was a
competition between two groups one a
group called rosetta at the university
of washington
and another one
in deep mind to develop proteins protein
folding algorithms
and this year both have reported their
results
in the open source and they've published
how proteins the most common proteins
that are part of biology fold
the reason this is important is the way
that they full determines the way they
interact with other cells
and it is the basis again of drug
discovery medicine how our bodies work
genetic expression and so forth these
proteins are super important these are
the kinds of discoveries that if they
were done by humans would would merit
nobel prizes
and this is happening right now
the way they do them is the same as i
described which is they generate
many many different candidates
and they evaluate them using ai and then
they choose the one that has the best
fit most optimal outcome and then they
release it and then that technology will
be used for the next ones and so forth
what do you hope the impact of this this
book will be
it's it's so all-encompassing in some
respects this topic
what is the
the hope with this book in terms of
impact or what people will do or how
they will change their
assumptions or beliefs
after being exposed to it
20 years ago when we started the
internet as you currently know it the
social media world many of the other
tools
no one debated what the impact on
society would be we were way busy
building these systems to great success
without understanding the impact
artificial intelligence is much more
powerful
than any of the technologies up till now
because as i mentioned
it's imprecise
it's emergent it's learning
and insightful
we need to understand how we're going to
deal with these things ahead of their
development
over and over again technologists build
these technologies without understanding
how they'll be used and misused
the goal of the book
is to lay out the fundamental questions
that society has to decide around these
emergent technologies
which will happen
and they will happen over the next five
to ten years
if our book
turns out to be the index case
where after reading this book and after
its publication
people say
holy crap i've got to get ahead of this
i've got to figure out a philosophy
around this i have to figure out a way
where humans can coexist
with these new systems it doesn't drive
humans crazy and makes the world better
not worse that's a great outcome from
our book
the age of a.i
and what a powerhouse of
the trio the co-authors involved
it's tremendously important and i'm
thrilled that we've had a chance to
deep dive into
so many facets of uh this subject that
has been of great interest to me but has
come along with great insecurity because
i come at it from a lay perspective
before we go i must i must ask how has
it been to start your own podcast
i enjoyed it it turns out to be harder
than i thought
because i actually had to prepare and i
had to get context and so forth but and
it it had it it has had an enough of an
impact that i will continue
reimagine with eric schmidt you're an
excellent conversationalist i've i'm i'm
i'm continually impressed uh
i don't need to do much that's the key
to interviewing is pick your subject
that's right it's all about the subject
it's a dual process but but i think it's
worth it's worth thinking about
in terms of what you and i do
you're a fan of richard feynman
when will there be a computer as smart
as richard feynman
yeah and the answer is a very long time
from now
and so we always like to focus on the
lawyers who will lose their jobs and the
politicians who will lose their jobs but
that's not how it actually works what
really happens is ai is going to be used
to eliminate repetitive jobs
jobs which are boring and so forth i
mentioned
vision
most of the military's activities are
watching things
i'd much rather have the computer
watching
and then when there's an exception say
hey something happened and alert a human
to take a look at it's a better use of
both the human and the computer
and so
the good news is that what you do and
what i do is not going to be replaced by
computers soon
i'll take it i will absolutely take it
and i encourage people to
read this book
the age of ai pick it up
you can find eric on twitter eric
schmidt and then certainly at
ericksmith.com we'll link to everything
including the book
and all resources companies technologies
mentioned in the show notes at tim.blog
podcast
eric thank you so much this has been
extremely extremely enjoyable and
educational for me so i appreciate you
taking the time
thank you tim
you